Previously on This American Life.
欢迎收听《美国生活》。
No income, no asset loans, that's a liar's loan. We are telling you to lie to us, effectively.
无收入、无资产证明的贷款，那就是“骗子贷款”。实际上，我们是在告诉你们：向我们撒谎吧。
I wouldn't have loaned me the money, and nobody that I know would have loaned me the money.
要是换作我，我才不会借钱给自己，我认识的人里也不会有人借钱给我。
This is where we have to talk about Alan Greenspan, right?
这时，我们不得不谈谈艾伦·格林斯潘了，对吧？
Yeah, we have to.
没错，我们必须谈谈他。
The balance sheets of these banks is, as far as we know, a huge lie.
据我们所知，这些银行的资产负债表就是一个巨大的谎言。
Over the last year, we've brought you many stories explaining exactly how the economy collapsed. We've heard about mortgage-backed securities and derivatives and bank balance sheets. And today, looking for a little ray of hope about our country's economic plight, we turn to the past.
在过去的一年里，我们为您讲述了许多故事，确切地解释了经济是如何崩溃的。我们听到了关于抵押贷款支持证券、衍生品和银行资产负债表的内容。今天，为了寻找我们国家经济困境的一丝希望，我们回顾了过去。
He was an amazing courtroom lawyer. He was relentless. He would not allow witnesses to duck and dodge. And he had a nearly photographic memory. His staff would marvel that he would read a briefing memo once and he would remember every name, every fact, every figure.
他是一位出色的出庭律师。他锲而不舍，绝不让证人逃避问题。他有着近乎过目不忘的记忆力。他的下属经常惊叹于他读一遍简报就能记住所有的名字、事实和数据。
This is Michael Perino, a law professor who's writing a book about Ferdinand Pecora. Pecora was the lead attorney in the hearings of the Senate Banking Committee back in the 1930s. And when Pecora got that job, he turned the hearings from an unimportant and not terribly useful exercise into a real investigation of Wall Street and the causes of the 1929 stock market collapse and The Great Depression.
这位是迈克尔·佩里诺，一位正在撰写关于费迪南德·佩科拉传记的法学教授。佩科拉是20世纪30年代参议院银行委员会听证会上的首席律师。当佩科拉接手这份工作时，他将原本不重要且用处不大的听证会，转变成了一场针对华尔街、针对1929年股市崩盘和大萧条原因的真正调查。
Pecora was a former district attorney, and he did this very, very well.
佩科拉曾任地方检察官，他非常、非常擅长这项工作。
He created outrage, and it was that anger and that frustration at Wall Street that created the political environment in which Congress had to pass the first federal securities legislation, had to pass new banking regulation, had to create the FDIC and federal insurance for bank deposits. Even Roosevelt drew a direct causal line between the wrongdoing that Pecora uncovered and his ability to push through legislation in that first 100 days of his administration, passage of so much legislation so quickly.
他激起了民愤，正是这种对华尔街的愤怒和挫败感，营造出了政治环境，迫使国会通过了首部联邦证券立法，实施了新的银行监管，并创建了联邦存款保险公司（FDIC）以保障银行存款。就连罗斯福总统也将佩科拉揭露的不端行为与他在执政前100天内推动立法——如此迅速地通过如此多法案——的能力之间，划上了一条直接的因果线。
Did they go into the hearings looking for bad guys, or did they go into the hearings looking to come up with an analysis of here's what went wrong and here's what we've got to fix and to have a kind of a teaching moment for the country?
他们参加听证会时是抱着寻找坏人的目的，还是为了对“哪里出了问题、我们需要修复什么”进行分析，从而给全国上一课？
It's a good question. Pecora described his job as trying to make what was going on in Wall Street, very complex and arcane transactions, he wanted to make them into common sense, to take these very complex transactions and really turn them into very simple morality tales of right and wrong.
这是个好问题。佩科拉将他的工作描述为：试图理清华尔街正在发生的那些复杂而晦涩的交易，他想让这些交易变得通俗易懂，将这些复杂的交易转化成关于是非曲直的简单道德故事。
One of the famous morality tales from the hearings, Pecora put Charles Mitchell into the witness chair. Mitchell was the head of National City Bank, which is an institution that we know today just as Citibank. And Pecora asked him about some bonds that his bank sold, bonds that had been issued by Latin American countries. The bank's own internal documents showed that the bank thought that maybe these bonds were no good.
听证会上著名的道德故事之一是，佩科拉让查尔斯·米切尔坐上了证人席。米切尔是国家城市银行（即今天的花旗银行）的行长。佩科拉问及他的银行出售的一些债券，这些债券是由拉美国家发行的。银行内部文件显示，银行自己认为这些债券可能毫无价值。
Their internal memos all said these securities present huge risk. There's great possibilities that these things are never going to get repaid. And National City never told any of that stuff to the investors.
他们的内部备忘录都写道：这些证券存在巨大风险，很有可能永远无法偿还。但国家城市银行从未向投资者透露过这些信息。
And when Pecora asked Mitchell about it, he seemed surprised. He said, why would the investors want to know anything about that? And that led directly to the passage of the first federal securities laws, the Securities Act of 1933, which required exactly that kind of disclosure when securities are sold to the public.
当佩科拉就此询问米切尔时，他显得很惊讶。他说：“为什么投资者会想知道这些？”这直接导致了美国首部联邦证券法——《1933年证券法》的通过，该法案明确要求在向公众出售证券时必须进行此类披露。
And there's also a show trial aspect to this, right? Like, it wasn't all substantive seriousness. Can you talk about that other part?
此外，这其中还有一种“作秀审判”的成分，对吧？它并不全是严肃的实质内容。你能谈谈这另一部分吗？
Yes. There were times when it descended into the absurd. During the hearings involving J.P. Morgan, this was the media event of the day. They brought special telegraph lines into the capital so that reporters could get their stories out quickly.
是的。有时听证会沦为了荒唐的闹剧。在涉及摩根大通的听证会期间，那是当天的媒体大事件。他们专门在国会大厦铺设了电报线路，以便记者能迅速发出报道。
In the committee room, Chairman Fletcher swears in J.P. Morgan, who explains the function of private bankers.
在委员会会议室里，弗莱彻主席让摩根大通宣誓，后者解释了私人银行家的职能。
This is one of the few times that flash photography or filming was allowed in the hearing room, and it led to the most famous photograph of the hearing, which came after a senator complained that all the media that had turned out to see J.P. Morgan had turned the proceedings into a circus.
这是听证会室罕见允许闪光灯摄影或拍摄的时刻之一，这产生了听证会上最著名的一张照片。照片出现在一名参议员抱怨说，所有赶来围观摩根大通的媒体把会议变成了一场马戏团表演之后。
Well, one of the promoters for Ringling Brothers Circus picked up on this comment, and he showed up the next day in the hearing room with a woman named Lea Graff, who was one of the circus midgets for Ringling Brothers. And he had the idea that what he termed the shortest woman in the world should sit on the lap of the world's richest man. And so there was Lea Graff sitting on the lap of J.P. Morgan.
结果，玲玲马戏团的一位推广人员抓住了这个评论，第二天他带了一位名叫莉亚·格拉夫的女性出现在听证会现场，她是玲玲马戏团的一位侏儒演员。他的想法是，让这个所谓的“世界上最矮的女人”坐在“世界上最富有的人”腿上。于是，就有了莉亚·格拉夫坐在摩根大通腿上的那一幕。
Reading these hearings, do you think we should do this now?
读着这些听证会的记录，你认为我们现在应该这样做吗？
You know, there's talk of doing it now. And my concern is how it's done. What I don't want to see is some hearings that are just the show without the substance.
你知道，现在确实有这种呼声。我担心的是怎么做。我不希望看到的是一场只有作秀而没有实质内容的听证会。
And do you feel like that's what we've gotten so far?
你觉得我们目前得到的正是这种结果吗？
So far, I think that's what we've gotten.
到目前为止，我认为是的。
So, basically, they call these executives, they yell at them about executive compensation.
所以，基本上，他们传唤这些高管，然后因为薪酬问题对他们大吼大叫。
Exactly. Just do a little public humiliation, and I think that doesn't do anybody any good.
没错。只是进行了一点公开羞辱，我认为这对任何人都没有好处。
We talked about this for a while. I told Michael Perino that I was surprised that President Obama, for all of his communication skills, hasn't really presented the public with a real analysis of what went wrong on Wall Street. The most the president usually says is that the problem is that the stuff that people did on Wall Street that got us into this mess was all perfectly legal.
我们讨论了一段时间。我告诉迈克尔·佩里诺，令我惊讶的是，奥巴马总统尽管拥有出色的沟通技巧，却并没有真正向公众展示关于华尔街到底出了什么问题的深入分析。总统通常最多说的是：华尔街那些导致我们陷入困境的勾当，在当时都是完全合法的。
Well, sitting in on this interview with me was NPR's Economics Correspondent Adam Davidson, who appears on our program all the time reporting on these issues, who has actually been looking into what kind of hearings Congress might hold on the banking crisis.
好吧，和我一起参加这次采访的还有NPR经济记者亚当·戴维森，他经常出现在我们的节目中报道这些问题，他一直在研究国会可能会针对银行危机举行什么样的听证会。
I talked to someone in Congress today, who asked that I not say who it was, but this person said that they don't want the Pecora hearings as a model. They see the 9/11 Commission as a model. And basically, this person who works in Congress for Congresspeople said we don't trust Congresspeople. If you have hearings inside Congress, it's going to be--
今天我和国会的一位人士谈过，他要求我保密，但此人说他们不希望把佩科拉听证会作为蓝本。他们把9/11委员会视为蓝本。基本上，这位为国会议员工作的人说，我们不信任国会议员。如果你在国会内部举行听证会，那将会是——
A circus.
一场马戏团表演。
Democrats versus Republicans. It's going to be ugly. If it's outside of Congress, that's your only shot.
民主党对阵共和党。那会很难看。如果是在国会之外举行，那才是你唯一的希望。
And I think the other issue that is in a lot of people's minds, quite frankly, is look at all the money that's coming from the financial services industry that flows into Congress, particularly into the committees that would actually hold these hearings. Are these really the people that we want to have? Maybe an independent commission is a better way to go than just having a Senate committee do the hearings.
而且坦率地说，我认为另一个许多人都在考虑的问题是，看看从金融服务行业流向国会、特别是流向那些本应举行听证会的委员会的巨额资金。他们真的是我们想要的人选吗？也许一个独立的委员会比仅仅让参议院委员会主持听证会要好得多。
So you're saying America needs an independent group of people not paid by banks and lobbyists, not partisan. Open-minded, fearless investigators.
所以你是说，美国需要一个独立的人员小组，他们不受银行和游说团体资助，不带党派偏见。是一群思想开放、无所畏惧的调查员。
I think the fewer conflicts we have on that committee, the better.
我认为该委员会的利益冲突越少越好。
Hey, Ira.
嘿，艾拉。
Yeah.
怎么了？
I think this is a job for us.
我觉得这活儿该我们干。
Well, until our government's hearings get going, if they ever get going, we today would like to make our own modest contribution, our own mini-hearing, because we do not want to wait. Our hearing will not last 17 months.
好吧，在政府的听证会——如果它们真能举行的话——开始之前，我们今天想做出一点微薄的贡献，举行我们自己的“迷你听证会”，因为我们不想再等了。我们的听证会将不会持续17个月。
We don't have subpoena power to force the most powerful people on Wall Street to come before us and testify, but we do have a question for our hearing, and it's this. There were regulators and there were watchdogs who were supposed to be overseeing the banks and the finance industry to make sure that things wouldn't blow up like they have. Clearly something went wrong. And we ask today, where were the watchmen?
我们没有传票权去强制华尔街最有权势的人来出席作证，但我们对听证会有个问题，那就是：曾有一些监管机构和监督人员本应监管银行和金融业，以确保事情不会像现在这样崩溃。显然有什么地方出了问题。今天我们问：守望者在哪里？
And so, I call this program to order. From WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our hearing today, in two parts, we have one investigator who looked at government watchmen, and one who looked at the watchmen in the private industry who were supposed to verify the safety of these financial instruments that collapsed. Stay with us.
所以，我宣布节目开始。这里是WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的听证会分为两部分，我们有一位调查员负责审查政府守望者，另一位负责审查私营行业内本应验证这些崩溃金融工具安全性的守望者。请继续收听。
OK, settle down. Order. Our first investigator we sent out with this assignment. We asked her to take one financial institution that really screwed up and tell us what was the deal with their regulators. Where were the government officials who were supposed to be overseeing that institution?
好了，安静。肃静。我们派出的第一位调查员领到了这个任务。我们让她选定一家真正搞砸了的金融机构，告诉我们他们的监管机构是怎么回事。那些本应监管该机构的政府官员去哪儿了？
Well, AIG seemed like a good institution to pick. The government has now committed $170 billion-- that's billion with a b-- into that company, which dwarfs the bailouts of GM, Citibank, and Bank of America. Our intrepid investigator, reporter Chana Joffe-Walt, first set out to answer what seems like a very simple question, which government regulator was supposed to be regulating AIG?
AIG似乎是个很好的选择。政府现在已经向该公司投入了1700亿美元——注意是带有“亿”字的十进制，这使得对通用汽车、花旗银行和美国银行的救助相形见绌。我们勇敢的调查员、记者查娜·乔夫-沃尔特，首先着手回答一个看似非常简单的问题：哪个政府监管机构本应监管AIG？
You and I, we read about the collapse of AIG on a Tuesday morning in the newspaper, but Eric Dinallo got a personal phone call Friday night. Dinallo's the insurance regulator for New York State, and it was AIG's chief financial officer on his cellphone. Eric, we need to discuss a liquidity problem.
你和我是在周二早上的报纸上读到AIG崩溃的消息的，但埃里克·迪纳洛在周五晚上接到了一个私人电话。迪纳洛是纽约州的保险监管官员，给他打私人手机的是AIG的首席财务官。他说：“埃里克，我们需要讨论一下流动性问题。”
I was in our family car driving to our cabin in Putnam County. When I heard the amounts, the enormity of it, I was shocked.
当时我正开车带着家人去普特南县的度假屋。当我听到那些数字，听到那种严重程度时，我震惊了。
What numbers did you hear that shocked you?
你听到的什么数字让你感到震惊？
Well, pretty quickly we started hearing numbers in the $40 billion range. This was just even over the phone Friday night.
很快我们就开始听到400亿美元左右的数字了。那还是周五晚上在电话里听到的。
Saturday morning, Dinallo heads into AIG. At the door, put the BlackBerry away, Sir, please. He does, and enters this conference room. There's no space at the table. AIG executives, Wall Street CEOs, bankers, advisers, treasury people, they're all there sitting next to a bunch of snacks no one has touched. AIG needs cash, and no one in the room is offering it up. Dinallo looks at his deputy, Hampton Finer. Finer looks around the room.
周六早上，迪纳洛前往AIG。在门口，有人说：“先生，请把黑莓手机收起来。”他照做了，然后进入了这个会议室。桌子旁没有空位。AIG的高管、华尔街CEO、银行家、顾问、财政部人员，他们都坐在那里，旁边还有一堆没人动过的零食。AIG需要现金，而在座的没有人愿意提供。迪纳洛看向他的副手汉普顿·费纳。费纳环顾四周。
I think what we thought to ourselves is this is the nightmare of-- this is every insurance supervisor's nightmare.
我想我们当时的内心想法是：这是噩梦——这是每一位保险监管员的噩梦。
And you were shocked by that?
你对此感到震惊吗？
Very shocked, yeah.
非常震惊，是的。
AIG's collapse was shocking to you and me, sure. It was shocking to people who held AIG insurance policies. OK. But these guys, Eric Dinallo and Hampton Finer, they are regulators, regulators, New York State insurance regulators, guys who talk about AIG in their morning meetings, guys who go out to AIG companies and do examinations, hold conferences about AIG quarterly reports. These are exactly the guys you hope will not be surprised when the enormous insurance giant based in New York calls its regulator and says we have no money.
AIG的崩溃当然让你我感到震惊。这对那些持有AIG保单的人来说令人震惊。好吧。但这些人，埃里克·迪纳洛和汉普顿·费纳，他们是监管者，纽约州的保险监管者，那些在晨会上谈论AIG的人，那些去AIG公司进行检查、就AIG季度报告召开会议的人。他们正是你希望在那个总部位于纽约的巨大保险巨头打电话给监管机构说“我们没钱了”时，不会感到惊讶的人。
I asked Superintendent Dinallo about that. You're the New York insurance regulator, doesn't that make you the guy in charge?
我问了迪纳洛局长这件事。你是纽约的保险监管官员，这难道不让你成为那个负责人吗？
We're the regulator for the domestic insurance companies that are domesticated in New York, but the other side was AIG Financial Products Division, that really was the part of the company that caused the taxpayer to have to put up the hundreds of billions of dollars that everyone is appropriately upset about.
我们是纽约本地保险公司的监管者，但另一面是AIG的金融产品部门，那部分公司才是导致纳税人不得不投入数千亿美元——大家对此感到愤慨是完全合理的——的部分。
So the healthy part, your part. That bad part, not your part.
所以，健康的部分是你管的，糟糕的部分不是你管的。
Well, yes. That's sort of a simple way of putting it, yeah.
嗯，是的。这是一种简单的说法，是的。
Where was Financial Products based?
金融产品部门的总部在哪里？
I think it was based in Connecticut-- Greenwich, I think-- and also in London.
我想是在康涅狄格州——我想是格林威治——还有伦敦。
A couple minutes of Google and some secretaries and the next day I'm asking Commissioner Thomas Sullivan the same question.
经过几分钟的谷歌搜索和秘书的协助，第二天我向专员托马斯·沙利文提出了同样的问题。
You're the insurance regulator of Connecticut. And AIG, huge insurance company, has their financial products group, which was the division that was dealing in all these exotic derivatives, they had an office in Connecticut. So aren't you responsible?
你是康涅狄格州的保险监管官员。AIG这家巨大的保险公司，其金融产品集团（也就是处理所有这些奇异衍生品的部门）在康涅狄格州设有办事处。所以你难道没有责任吗？
No. Financial products is not an insurance company. AIG--
没有。金融产品部门不是一家保险公司。AIG——
But AIG is an insurance company.
但AIG是一家保险公司。
Well, AIG the holding company is not an insurance company.
嗯，AIG控股公司并不是一家保险公司。
Next, I called London. I called other places where AIG had big offices: Japan, China. I called France. AIG Financial Products had a subsidiary in France.
接下来，我给伦敦打了电话。我给AIG设有大型办事处的其他地方打了电话：日本、中国。我给法国打了电话。AIG金融产品在法国有一家子公司。
I am Corrine Dromer, and I am deputy director of communications.
我是科琳·德罗默，我是通讯副主任。
Great. And Dromer, do I spell it--?
太好了。德罗默，拼写是——？
D-R-O-M-E-R.
D-R-O-M-E-R。
Great, OK.
好的，太棒了。
I'm speaking off the record only.
我说的话仅限非正式交流。
Oh, remember I just asked if I could record our conversation?
哦，记得我刚才问过能不能录音吗？
You can record, of course, but it's really off the record.
你当然可以录音，但这确实是非正式交流。
OK, anyway, Dromer just proceeded to tell me in, I have to say, the most snooty way possible, obviously the subsidiary was regulated by the French regulator, but the subsidiary didn't mess up the global economy, Financial Products did, and Financial Products is a US company. France, not responsible for American mess-ups.
好吧，无论如何，德罗默继续以一种我不得不说最傲慢的方式告诉我，显然该子公司是由法国监管机构监管的，但该子公司并没有搞垮全球经济，是金融产品部门搞砸的，而金融产品部门是一家美国公司。法国，不对美国的烂摊子负责。
AIG has approximately 400 regulators in 150 countries and all 50 states. I think I called 35 of them. Do you know how hard it is to get a regulator to even talk to you, to even say the words, not my fault? Which, by the way, is what every single one of them told me. It sounds crazy, right? And unsatisfying and frustrating and confusing.
AIG在150个国家和所有50个州大约有400个监管机构。我想我给其中的35个打了电话。你知道让一个监管者开口说话、甚至说出“这不是我的错”这几个字有多难吗？顺便说一句，他们每个人都是这么告诉我的。这听起来很疯狂，对吧？让人不满、沮丧且困惑。
But also, unfortunately, mostly legit. AIG was this enormous company, gigantic international operations, $1 trillion in assets. Those 400 regulators, they were each handed a small chunk of the monster.
但遗憾的是，这大部分也是合法的。AIG是一家庞大的公司，拥有巨大的国际业务，资产达1万亿美元。那400个监管者，每个人都被分配到了这头怪兽的一小块。
I asked Eric Dinallo, the New York insurance regulator, about that.
我问了纽约保险监管官员埃里克·迪纳洛关于这件事。
What percentage of AIG would you say that you were responsible for looking after?
你觉得你负责看管的AIG资产占多少比例？
I'd have to check. I don't know the exact percentage of the Property and Life Divisions put together internationally, so I don't want to speculate.
我得核实一下。我不知道财产和人寿保险部门加在一起在国际上的确切百分比，所以我不想推测。
Can we find out?
我们能查出来吗？
Yeah, yeah, we can do that.
可以，可以，我们可以做到。
Thanks.
谢谢。
This took 18 minutes, four men in suits, one computer, two cell phones, and I'm not sure how many calculators, to figure out what portion of AIG this one office is in charge of. Here's just a little piece of all that.
花了18分钟，四个人穿着西装，一台电脑，两部手机，还有不知道多少计算器，才算出这个办事处负责AIG的哪一部分。这只是其中一小部分。
Is that OK? Yeah? Did the numbers add up about the same? What did you get? What? And then he started banging-- and then the reporter's going to say, and then he started banging his head on the wall.
这样可以吗？对吧？数字加起来差不多吗？你得到了什么？什么？然后他开始撞——然后记者说，然后他开始用头撞墙。
He did bang his head on the wall. And then--
他确实撞墙了。然后——
I think on an assets basis, it would be somewhere between 7% and 10%.
我想以资产基础来看，应该在7%到10%之间。
Does that mean that Connecticut has 5% and Missouri has 3% and--
那是不是意味着康涅狄格州有5%，密苏里州有3%，然后——
Oh, I'm sure.
哦，我确定。
--Alabama has 4%?
——阿拉巴马州有4%？
Yeah, I'm sure if you went through and did an analysis, it would definitely be segmented similarly, actually globally.
是的，我肯定如果你去做个分析，全球范围内肯定也是类似的分段。
And that means that all of those states have their own individual regulators, all those countries have their own individual regulators, maybe the regions have regulators.
这意味着所有这些州都有各自独立的监管者，所有这些国家都有各自独立的监管者，也许区域也有监管者。
Yes, that's our system.
是的，这就是我们的系统。
In other words, Eric Dinallo is great at property and life and car and death insurance in New York State. He is not-- no offense, Dinallo-- a star at airplane leasing, insurance in Bangladesh, real estate in Tokyo. So Dinallo focuses in on his one thing. He's given 7% to 10% of AIG, and he says, I regulated my 7% to 10% very well, thank you.
换句话说，埃里克·迪纳洛非常擅长纽约州的财产、人寿、汽车和死亡保险。他并不是——冒犯了，迪纳洛——飞机租赁、孟加拉国保险、东京房地产方面的专家。所以迪纳洛专注于他的一块。他被分配了AIG的7%到10%，他说：“谢谢，我把我这7%到10%监管得非常好。”
The problem was that all these regulators with their 5% here and 3% over here, it didn't all add up to 100% of the company. There were a few percentage points missing, parts of the company that nobody had specific jurisdiction over. And that right there became the story of what went wrong with AIG. Federal Reserve Chairman Ben Bernanke told Congress:
问题在于，所有这些拿着5%在这里、3%在那里的监管者，加起来并不能覆盖公司的100%。有几个百分点缺失了，那是公司里没有人拥有明确管辖权的部分。而那一点恰恰成了AIG出问题的核心故事。美联储主席本·伯南克告诉国会：
AIG exploited a huge gap in the regulatory system. There was no oversight of the Financial Products Division.
AIG利用了监管体系中的一个巨大漏洞。对金融产品部门没有任何监管。
The Financial Products Division was the part of the company that bought and sold derivatives, which, as you may have heard, were the complicated financial instruments that nearly sunk AIG. And Bernanke was saying no one was regulating that part of the company. And for months, that story stuck.
金融产品部门是公司中买卖衍生品的那部分，正如你可能听说过的那样，那些复杂的金融工具差点拖垮了AIG。伯南克说没有人监管公司的那部分。几个月来，这个说法一直占据主导地位。
And then one day, Donald Kohn, also with the Fed, he's telling that story. He's in a Congressional hearing, and he's going on about how, unfortunately, no one was watching that part of the company and no one was watching over the whole thing, the whole of AIG. Senators dutifully asking follow-ups, and then they get interrupted. A hunched man peeking over his glasses says, um, we were, we were in charge, we screwed up.
后来有一天，美联储的唐纳德·科恩也在讲述这个故事。他在国会听证会上，不停地说着不幸的是没有人看管公司的那部分，也没有人看管整个AIG。参议员们尽职尽责地跟进提问，然后他们被中途打断了。一个驼背的人从眼镜上方看过来，说道：“嗯，我们是，我们负责，我们搞砸了。”
Senator, may I make a comment.
参议员，我能发表个评论吗？
Yeah.
可以。
It's time for OTS to raise their hand and say, we have some responsibility and accountability here. This entity was deemed a savings and loan holding company. We were deemed an acceptable regulator for both US domestic and international operations.
是时候让储蓄管理局（OTS）举起手来说：我们在这方面有一些责任和问责。该实体被视为储蓄贷款控股公司。我们被视为美国国内和国际业务的可接受监管者。
There it was, Scott Polakoff, interim director of the Office of Thrift Supervision, OTS, saying, blame us. Thrifts are the same as savings and loans. They're a type of bank. And the OTS regulates thrifts and holding companies that own thrifts. And what Scott Polakoff was saying here is, we were the thrift regulator and we were the regulator for the whole company, what's called the lead regulator, for all of AIG. We were supposed to fill in all those gaps.
就在那一刻，观看听证会的人都能看出，国会议员们感到很震惊。他们看起来确实有些难以置信。参议员梅尔·马丁内斯凑过来。
At this moment, you can tell, watching the hearing, that congressmen, they're kind of taken aback. They actually seem sort of incredulous. Senator Mel Martinez leans in.
波拉科夫先生，我想——波拉科夫主任——我想问你，你承认或许你就是我们一直在寻找的监管者，这让我很震惊。我想我们一直以为没有这么一个人。
Mr. Polakoff, I wanted to-- Director Polakoff-- wanted to ask you, I was struck by your acknowledgement that perhaps you are the regulator that we've been looking for. I think that we had assumed that there wasn't one.
波拉科夫说：“是的，我是那个人，先生。”两周后的听证会上，来自得克萨斯州的参议员杰布·亨萨林问波拉科夫：“等等，你是这么说的吗？”
Polakoff says, yes, I'm the one, sir. And Senator Jeb Hensarling from Texas, in a hearing two weeks later, he asks Polakoff, wait, did you say that?
我相信我在之前的一个问题回答中听到过，我相信我听到你说OTS在2004年就应该停止你提到的那项业务，即CDS和AIG证券借贷承诺。我理解正确吗？
I believe I heard, in an earlier answer to one of the questions, I believe I heard you say that OTS in 2004 should have stopped the book of business that I think you were alluding to, the CDS and the AIG securities lending commitments. Did I understand you correctly?
是的，先生。
Yes, sir.
所以，如果你说2004年就应该停止，那意味着你当时本可以停止它是吧？
So, if you said you should have stopped it in 2004, that implies you could have stopped it in 2004. Is that correct?
是的，先生。
Yes, sir.
参议员亨萨林接着说，所以并不是你没有权力，不是缺乏资源，不是缺乏经验，你只是完全犯了一个错误？波拉科夫再次说：“是的，先生。”
Senator Hensarling then says, so it wasn't that you didn't have the authority, it wasn't a lack of resources, it wasn't a lack of experience, you just flat made a mistake? Polakoff says, once again, yes, sir.
所以，这个家伙站出来说：“是的，我，我就是你们一直在寻找的那个人。”大家都有点——“你？你是谁？”
So, here's this guy standing up and saying, yes, me, I'm the one you've been looking for. And everyone kind of goes, you? Who are you?
我猜你从未听说过储蓄管理局（OTS）。OTS是最小的联邦银行监管机构，也是最年轻的，只有20岁。我确实给OTS打过几次电话。没有人跟我谈过AIG。公关人员告诉我：“我们在国会作证过两次，不会再说更多了。”
I'm guessing you've never heard of the Office of Thrift Supervision. The OTS is the smallest federal bank regulator, and it's the youngest, 20 years old. I did call the OTS several times. No one talked to me about AIG. The press guy told me, we've testified before Congress twice, we're not going to go beyond that.
于是我开始给那些监管专家打电话，比如帕特里夏·麦考伊。她是康涅狄格大学的法学教授，业余时间喜欢拿着纸笔做“银行尸检”。她会研究破产机构，看看出了什么问题。你知道，纯粹为了好玩。所以一天晚上，麦考伊在制作一份07年和08年主要银行倒闭的图表。
So then I started calling the regulation expert people, like Patricia McCoy. She's a law professor at the University of Connecticut, someone who in her free time sits down with a pen and paper and does bank autopsies. She'll research failed institutions, look at what went wrong. You know, for fun. So one night, McCoy's making this graph of major bank failures from '07 and '08.
那是深夜，我习惯深夜工作。我填好了资产规模，然后需要做点研究看看谁是监管者。当我开始敲入“OTS，OTS，OTS”时，我心想：这个机构到底发生了什么？它一直处于雷达之下，我们竟然没察觉。
It was late at night. I tend to work late at night. I had filled in the asset sizes, and then I had to do a little research to see who the regulators were. And when I started typing in OTS, OTS, OTS, I went, what happened at this agency? It's been flying under the radar and we didn't notice.
你在旁边写下OTS的机构有哪些？
Which institutions were you seeing and writing OTS in next to them?
印地麦克银行、华盛顿互助银行、唐尼储蓄贷款、NetBank。
IndyMac, Washington Mutual, Downey Savings and Loan, NetBank.
你可能认出其中一些名字。例如，印地麦克银行，这次危机中最昂贵的银行倒闭案，由OTS监管。第二昂贵的，联合银行，由OTS监管。有史以来倒闭的最大银行，华盛顿互助银行，OTS。OTS的其他“光辉事迹”还包括全国金融公司和AIG。
You might recognize some of those names. For instance, IndyMac, the most expensive bank failure of this crisis, regulated by the OTS. Second most expensive, Bank United, regulated by the OTS. The largest bank ever to fail, Washington Mutual, OTS. Other OTS claims to fame, Countrywide and AIG.
储蓄管理局的声誉是：它是最软弱、最松懈的，实际上对最恶劣的非优质贷款非常友好。
The reputation of Office of Thrift Supervision was that it was the weakest and the laxest and it was, indeed, outright friendly to the worst of the non-prime lending.
这位是威廉·布莱克。他是密苏里大学堪萨斯城分校的教授。他曾在90年代初担任过储蓄管理局的律师。布莱克说，OTS能对抗全球最大的保险公司AIG的想法，嗯——
This is William Black. He's professor at the University of Missouri-Kansas City. And he used to work as a lawyer for the Office of Thrift Supervision back in the early '90s. Black says the idea that the OTS could ever go up against AIG, the world's largest insurance company, well--
根本没戏。这就像是世界重量级冠军对抗65磅、13岁的班级弱鸡。那就是OTS。
No contest. It's like the super heavyweight of the world going up against the 65-pound, 13-year-old class weakling. That was the OTS.
你思考机构是如何得到它们的监管者的，你会想，它们肯定是被指派的，对吧？就像你被指派了一个老板，有人告诉你谁是你的监管者。
You think about how institutions get their regulators, and you just think, they must get assigned one, right? It's like, you get assigned a boss, someone tells you who your regulator is.
不，如果你是一家国民银行，你有四个选择。也许你已经知道了，但这对我来说简直疯了。金融机构，它们自己选择监管者。它们进行“监管者购物”。而当AIG在进行监管者购物时，OTS看起来相当不错。
No, if you're a national bank, you have four choices. And maybe you knew this already, but this seemed insane to me. Financial institutions, they choose their regulators. They go regulator shopping. And when AIG was regulator shopping, the OTS looked pretty good.
OTS实际上是因为另一个监管机构彻底搞砸了——联邦住房贷款银行委员会——才被创建的。该委员会曾监管储蓄贷款，直到80年代末爆发储蓄贷款危机，国会废除了它并创建了OTS。
The OTS was actually created because another regulator really messed up, the Federal Home Loan Bank Board. It used to regulate savings and loans until the savings and loan crisis in the late '80s, at which point Congress abolished it and created the OTS.
我和几位在那个前身机构“银行委员会”工作过的人谈过，他们描述说，在那一天，OTS成立的那天，他们离开了办公室，这些机构员工走过马路去了一家酒店。他们打开电视，坐着观看老布什总统站在讲台上宣布：“美国再也不会允许任何受保机构在没有足够资金的情况下运营。”然后机构员工看着总统践踏了他们的机构。
And I talked to several people who worked for that predecessor agency, The Bank Board, and they described that, on that day, the day the OTS was created, they left the office, these agency employees, and they walked across the street to a hotel. They turned on the TV, and they sat and watched the first President Bush stand up at a podium and declare, never again will America allow any insured institution to operate without enough money. And then the agency employees watched as the president trashed their agency.
新闻发布会结束了，他们关掉电视，离开酒店，穿过马路，回去工作。没过多久，有人过来换了招牌：储蓄管理局。
The press conference ended, they turned off the TV, left the hotel, crossed the street, and went back to work. Pretty soon, someone came by and changed the sign, the Office of Thrift Supervision.
所以这就有了这个新生的储蓄贷款监管者，它有一段时间确实试图改变自己的方式。新的管理层带来了新的管理方法，但OTS处境艰难。储蓄贷款机构纷纷倒闭，这对于OTS来说是个问题，一个严重的问题，因为——这带出了关于我们监管系统运行方式的另一个疯狂事实——联邦银行监管者是由银行（也就是它们本应监管的对象）支付工资的。它们没有政府预算。它们监管的银行越多，钱就越多。
So there was this newborn savings and loan regulator, and for a while it did try to change its ways. A new administration brought in new management, but the OTS was in a tough spot. Savings and loans were dropping like flies, and this was a problem for the OTS, a serious problem, because-- and this brings us to an even more insane fact about the way our system of regulation works-- federal bank regulators, they're paid by the banks, the people they're supposed to be regulating. They don't get a government budget. The more banks they regulate, the more money they have.
所以，如果你是储蓄监管者，而成百上千家储蓄机构倒闭了，这对你来说就是个问题。
So, if you're the thrift regulator, and hundreds of thrifts just drop dead, that's a problem for you.
OTS的收入不断流失，正在缩减员工队伍。所以员工担心会丢掉工作。当然，老板们担心，如果机构越来越少，为什么还需要这个机构？所以他们拼命试图让银行进行转换，以便它们能由储蓄管理局监管，这样OTS就能获得收入并维持运营。
The OTS was losing revenue and losing revenue, and it was shrinking its staff. So the staff feared that they would lose their jobs. And of course, the bosses feared, why do they need an agency if there are fewer and fewer institutions? So they were desperate to try to get banks to convert so they'd be regulated by the Office of Thrift Supervision and the Office of Thrift Supervision would get the revenue and be able to stay in business.
现在，OTS不能召开新闻发布会说：“嘿，我们要关门大吉了。我们将成为镇上最宽松的监管者。快过来注册吧。”不，相反，他们去了行业会议。他们谈论他们提供的服务，谈论你怎么能做更多的事情。他们确实确保出现在其他种类的发布会上，让人们意识到它们的存在。
Now, the OTS couldn't hold a press conference and say, hello, we're having a going-out-of-business sale. We'll be the laxest regulator in town. Come on down, sign up. No, instead they went to industry meetings. They talked about the services they offered, how you could do more things. And they did make sure to show up at other kinds of press conferences, make their presence known.
比如有一次，一群联邦监管者聚集在一起宣布一场放松监管、剪断红头文件的运动，储蓄管理局局长詹姆斯·吉勒兰出现在拍照现场。顺便说一句，吉勒兰没有回复电话，所以帕特里夏·麦考伊和威廉·布莱克描绘了这幅图景。
Like, this one time a bunch of federal regulators were getting together to announce a campaign to ease regulation, cut through red tape, and James Gilleran, the head of the Office of Thrift Supervision, he shows up for the photo op. Gilleran, just by the way, did not return calls, so Patricia McCoy and William Black, they paint the picture.
他们本质上是站成一个马蹄形。他们背后是一个横幅，宣布新的监管放松运动。
They were essentially standing in a horseshoe. Behind them is a banner that announces the new regulatory relief campaign.
他们都咧着嘴大笑，站在一堆联邦法规上方，以展示他们剪断所有联邦法规的意图。
And they're all grinning broadly and poised over a stack of the federal regulations to demonstrate their intention to cut through all the federal regulations.
其他官方监管者带着修枝剪出现在发布会上，每个人都举起手中的工具准备修剪。非常风景如画。吉勒兰带了一把链锯。
The other official regulators showed up at the press conference with garden shears, and each of them is holding up their instrument ready to clip. Very picturesque. Gilleran showed up with a chainsaw.
OTS的家伙拿着链锯？
The OTS guy is holding a chainsaw?
是的，他站在前面。
Yes, and he's standing in front.
公司收到了信息。2000年，通用汽车收购了一家储蓄银行。第二年，GE也是如此。几年后，H&R Block拥有了一家储蓄银行。2000年，一家名为AIG的大型保险企业集团在特拉华州开设了一家小型储蓄贷款银行。它仅占AIG总资产负债表的千分之一，但这意味着AIG可以获得OTS作为其主要监管者，监管其全部业务。全部。控股公司监管者，国际监管者。
Companies got the message. In 2000, General Motors bought a thrift. Next year, so did GE. A few years after that, H&R Block had a thrift. And in 2000, a large insurance conglomerate called AIG opened a small savings and loan in Delaware. It was 1/1000 of AIG's total balance sheet, but that meant AIG could get OTS as its lead regulator, overseeing its entire business. All of it. The holding company regulator, the international regulator.
给世界各地的监管者打电话询问“你们谁在AIG的问题上搞砸了？”极其令人沮丧。但和人们谈论OTS，我得说，听到“伙计，他们搞砸了”真是让人相当满足。终于，有一个清晰明了的简单答案，一个容易确定的反派，太好了。本来应该到此为止的。
Calling up the world's regulators and asking, which one of you screwed up with AIG? Extremely frustrating. But talking to people about the OTS, I've got to say it's pretty satisfying hearing, man, they screwed up. Finally, it's clear-cut, simple answer, easy villain, great. Should have stopped there.
我不在乎谁是监管者。我不认为他们能发现这一点。我希望我们不要被带到那个旁支节目里去。被带入旁支节目实际上并不能解决问题。
I don't care who was the regulator. I don't think they would have caught this. And I hope we don't get diverted to that side show. It's getting diverted to side shows that unfortunately doesn't solve things.
这位是迈克·罗斯特。他是一位资深的监管律师，他说，当然，如果你想抨击OTS，尽管去，但要把你的愤怒分散一点。首先，给国会留点。
This is Mike Roster. He's a veteran regulation lawyer, and he says, sure, you can dump on the OTS if you want, but spread out your anger a little. First of all, save some for Congress.
回到2000年12月，国会通过了立法，使得监管AIG导致所有问题的那个特定部分变得极其困难。这是一项名为《商品期货现代化法案》的法律。它规定，某些类型的衍生品——那些处于AIG问题核心的复杂金融工具——不能由通常监管此类事物的联邦机构监管。
Back in December of 2000, Congress passed legislation that made it incredibly hard to regulate the exact part of AIG that caused all the problems. It was this law called the Commodity Futures Modernization Act. And it said, certain kinds of derivatives-- those complicated financial instruments at the heart of AIG's problems-- cannot be regulated by the federal agencies that typically watch over that kind of thing.
让我重复一遍。2000年，国会决定联邦监管者不能监管导致AIG陷入麻烦的东西。克林顿总统签署了该法案。事后看来，这似乎很疯狂，但在当时，衍生品仍是一个相当小的市场。政治家们只是没有看到风险，这意味着最终，即使OTS真的、真的想彻底监管AIG，在理论上，作为主要监管者，他们可以做到，但他们必须介入并做一些事情，而那些事情本是该其他联邦机构的专业职责，国会刚刚禁止该机构做这些事。
Let me just repeat that. In 2000, Congress decided federal regulators could not regulate the thing that got AIG into trouble. President Clinton signed that act into law. In retrospect, it seems crazy, but at the time derivatives were still a pretty small market. Politicians just didn't see the risk, which means, in the end, that even if the OTS had really, really wanted to regulate the hell out of AIG, in theory, as the lead overarching regulator, they could do it, but they would have had to step in and do things that were really the specialized job of this other federal agency, a job Congress had just barred that agency from doing.
罗斯特说，也别把愤怒全用在国会身上。那些和AIG做交易的其他公司呢？顺便说一句，所有这些公司都有监管者，他们认为一切看起来都很棒。他们认为AIG一切都很好，不是因为OTS在监管工作上做得有多出色。罗斯特说，没有人关注OTS。
And Roster says, don't use up all your anger on Congress either. How about all those other firms that did deals with AIG? All firms with regulators, by the way, who thought everything looked great. And they thought everything looked great at AIG, not because the OTS was doing such a bang-up job regulating. No one, Roster says, was paying any attention to the OTS.
不，不。现实不是这样的。如果你在和AIG进行交易，如果你在从他们那里购买数十亿美元的保险，你不是在看OTS。你实际上是在看标准普尔和穆迪的评级。AIG获得了AAA评级，评级机构里都是非常聪明的人。
No, no. The reality is no. If you're doing trades with AIG, if you're buying billions of dollars of insurance from them, you're not looking at the OTS. You're actually looking at the Standard & Poor's and Moody's ratings. There is AIG getting a Triple A rating, and those are very smart people at the rating agencies.
所以，如果你想知道该把AIG的问题归咎于哪个监管者，那不是州保险监管者，也不是伦敦，绝对不是法国，储蓄管理局正式承担了责任，但我们也可以指责国会和评级机构。评级机构，它们本应查看每一只债券、每一份衍生品，以确保它是安全的。
So, if you want to know which regulator to blame AIG on, it's not the state insurance regulators, or London, definitely not France, the Office of Thrift Supervision officially takes the blame, but then we can also point the finger at Congress and the rating agencies. The rating agencies, now, they were supposed to be looking at each and every bond, each and every derivative, to make sure it was safe.
评级机构是另一个更大的麻烦，我们一会儿就会打开这个话题。
The rating agencies are a whole other can of worms, and one we will open in just a minute.
好吧，我自己都说不出更好的话了。谢谢你，查娜·乔夫-沃尔特。我们准备好了开罐器，也准备好了迎接接下来要处理的“麻烦”。我说的麻烦并不是要贬低我们国家金融行业里的任何人。芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际公司的节目稍后继续。
Well, I couldn't have said that better myself. Thank you, Chana Jaffe-Walt. We have can openers at the ready and worms ready for the close-up. And by worms I don't mean to disparage anybody in our nation's financial industry. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。会议开始。请肃静，请肃静。好吧，我们在节目中渴望那种在1930年股灾后出现的听证会，当时调查员费迪南德·佩科拉让复杂的华尔街诡计变得人人都能理解。所以，因为我们现在还没有那样的听证会，我们今天就在这里举行我们自己的听证会。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Come to order. Come to order, please. Well, we in our program are hungry for the kind of hearings that they had back in the 1930s after the stock market crash, where investigator Ferdinand Pecora made complicated Wall Street shenanigans understandable to everybody. And so, because we don't have those yet, we are holding our own hearings today, right now.
在这些听证会上，我们现在将注意力转向信用评级机构。当所有那些拖垮我们经济的金融工具——抵押贷款支持证券、衍生品，所有那些东西——最初发行时，三家评级机构：标准普尔、穆迪和惠誉，给了其中许多东西最高的AAA评级，意味着风险极低，尽可能安全。
And we turn our attention now in these hearings to the credit ratings agencies. When all those financial instruments that brought down our economy, the mortgage-backed securities, the derivatives, all that stuff, were originally issued, three rating agencies, Standard & Poor's, Moody's, and Fitch, gave many of those things their top rating of Triple A, meaning very low risk, as safe as can be.
由于这些出色的评级，数万亿美元流入了这些金融工具和房地产市场，当然，制造了一个巨大的泡沫。当然，这些评级结果被证明是不正确的。例如，标准普尔已经将其约一半的AAA级降级，有些甚至降到了最低水平的CCC级。
Because of the great ratings, trillions of dollars went into those financial instruments and into the housing market, creating a big bubble, of course. And of course, the ratings did not turn out to be correct. Standard & Poor's, for example, has downgraded roughly half, half, of its triple As, some way down to almost its lowest level, the Triple C.
评级机构只有一项工作要做：评估这些东西的风险。这看起来相当清楚。在那项工作上，它们失败了。那么它们应该为全球金融危机承担很大责任吗？
The rating agencies just had one job to do, assess how risky these things were. That seems pretty clear. On that job, they failed. So should they take a lot of blame for the global financial crisis?
好吧，我们的听证会继续。这里是亚历克斯·布隆伯格和大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
Well, our hearing continues. Here's Alex Blumberg and David Kestenbaum.
几乎任何发行债券的人都会从评级机构获得评级。公司、城市，甚至整个国家都会被评级。标准普尔给了IBM A+评级。圣路易斯县R-9学区获得了AA-。阿根廷，B-。
Pretty much anyone who issues a bond gets a rating from the rating agencies. Companies, cities, even entire countries get rated. Standard & Poor's gives IBM an A+. The Saint Louis County School District R-9 gets a double A-. Argentina, B-.
有一本旧书，《穆迪投资分析，蒸汽铁路，1917年》。阿迪朗达克铁路？AAA评级。阿伯丁和罗克菲什铁路？离那个远点。他们得了B。所以在大约100年的时间里，这就是评级机构所做的事情，试图回答一个简单而关键的问题：如果我借钱给某人，买他们的债券，我能拿回我的钱吗？
There's this old book, Moody's Analysis of Investments, Steam Railroads, 1917. Adirondack Railroad? Triple A rating. Aberdeen & Rockfish Railroad? Stay away from that one. They got a B. So for something like 100 years, this is what the rating agencies have done, tried to answer one simple and critical question, if I lend someone money, buy one of their bonds, am I going to get my money back?
但在20世纪80年代初，出现了一种不同类型的债券。今天它们有很多名字：抵押贷款支持证券、担保债务凭证。它们都属于结构化金融这个大标题下，这基本上就是你听说过很多的那种东西。数以千计的贷款或抵押贷款集中在一起打包，然后作为债券出售。
But in the early 1980s, a different kind of bond came along. Today they go by many names, mortgage-backed securities, collateralized debt obligations. They all fall under the broad heading of structured finance, which is basically that thing you've heard a lot about. Thousands of loans or mortgages pooled together in bundles and then sold as bonds.
它们的数量不断增长。在过去十年里，华尔街创造了数万亿美元的这类债券。评级机构给它们评了级。弗兰克·雷特曾在其中一家机构工作，标准普尔，结构化金融部门。
And their numbers grew. Over the last decade, Wall Street created trillions of dollars of these bonds. And the rating agencies rated them. Frank Raiter worked for one of these agencies, Standard & Poor's, in the Structured Finance Division.
有一段时间，至少在2005年、2004-2005年，我们是标准普尔内部增长最快、利润最高的部门。
We were the fastest-growing, most profitable group within Standard & Poor's for a while, at least in 2005, 2004-2005.
这些天，弗兰克·雷特住得离华尔街很远。事实上，他完全在手机信号覆盖范围之外。他正在弗吉尼亚州的乡村开垦一个小农场。他确实有一个办公室，但里面有一只乌龟。
These days, Frank Raiter lives far away from Wall Street. In fact, he's out of cellphone reach entirely. He's clearing himself a little farm in rural Virginia. He does have an office, but it's got a turtle in it.
我之所以想和他谈谈，是因为弗兰克·雷特在标准普尔成立之初，正是结构化金融产品真正起飞的时候。他是那些必须找出为它们打字母分数最佳方法的团队成员之一。
And the reason I wanted to talk to him is that Frank Raiter was at Standard & Poor's at the very beginning, when the structured finance products were really taking off. And he was on the team people that had to figure out the best way to give them letter grades.
所以假设你有一个抵押贷款支持证券。它由大约5000个左右的抵押贷款组成。基本上，你必须估计那5000人中每个人有多安全，他们违约的可能性有多大。
So let's say you had a mortgage-backed security. It's made up of, like, 5,000 or so mortgages. Basically, you have to estimate how safe each of those 5,000 people is, how likely they are to default.
雷特说，当他刚开始在标准普尔工作时，他们有各种借款人的数据库，有信誉好的，也有信誉差的。为了找出借款人违约的可能性，他们聘请了一家公司，一家数学公司。那家数学公司根据一个实际方程为他们制作了一个计算机模型。
Raiter says when he first started working at Standard & Poor's, they had databases on all kinds of borrowers, ones with good credit, bad credit. And to figure out how likely the borrower is to default, they hired a company, a math company. And the math company made them a computer model based on an actual equation.
它被用于密码破译、加密以及类似领域。
It's used in codebreaking and encryption and areas like that.
有一个实际的方程。确实有一个实际的方程。
There was an actual equation. There is an actual equation.
哦，是的。有一个实际的计量经济学方程。
Oh yeah. There's an actual econometric equation.
你见过那个方程吗？
Did you ever see the equation?
哦，是的。
Oh yeah.
它看起来是什么样的？
What'd it look like?
看起来有很多希腊字母。
It looked like a lot of Greek letters.
所以，弗兰克在标准普尔的前五年左右，事情进展得相当顺利，他说。他们采用关于借款人行为的历史数据，输入模型，并使用结果发布评级。但后来，在21世纪初，正如我们所听到的，银行开始向以前无法获得贷款的人发放抵押贷款，那些信用评分低、首付为零，且不说明自己从事何种工作的人。
So, for the first five years or so that Frank was with Standard & Poor's, things went pretty well, he says. They were taking their historical data about borrower behavior, feeding it into the model, and using the results to issue their ratings. But then, in the early 2000s, as we've heard, banks started issuing mortgages to people who wouldn't have gotten them before, people with bad credit scores, putting no money down and not saying what kind of job they had.
关于这种借款人会表现如何，并没有多少历史记录。方程无法真正处理它们，这让弗兰克很担心。他说，他们不得不基本上猜测违约概率，把“魔术数字”放进模型里。雷特说，在他看来唯一可行的方法是，如果他们开始收集这些新借款人的数据，看看他们随时间的表现，这样他们就会有一些真实的经济历史数据可以输入到方程里。
There wasn't much history on how this kind of borrower would behave. The equation couldn't really handle them, and that worried Frank. He says they had to basically guess at the default probabilities, put magic numbers into the model. Raiter says the only way that seemed OK to him was if they started collecting data on these new borrowers to see how they performed over time, so they'd have some real historical data to put into the equation.
但当他去找老板说：“我们需要一个新模型，我们需要收集更多数据”时，这就是他得到的答案。
But when he went to his bosses saying, we need a new model, we need to collect more data, this is the answer he got.
你拥有94%的市场份额。如果我们建立一个新模型，你也不会得到更多了。对他们来说，这只是一个工具，而我们用它赚了很多钱，所以为什么要改变它？
You've got 94% market share. You're not going to get any more if we build a new model. To them it was just a tool, and we were making a lot of money with it, so why change it?
他们在谈话中具体对你这么说过吗：“看，我们有94%的市场份额，为什么要一个更好的模型？”
Did they say that to you specifically in conversations, look, we have 94% market share, like, why do we need a better model?
是的。那是我在几个场合进行的谈话。
Yeah. That was a conversation that I had on several occasions.
他们本应该直接说：“你知道吗？我们没有关于这个新产品的足够信息来给予评级。”但他们做不到。
They should have just said, you know what? We don't have enough information about this new product to ascribe a rating to it, but they couldn't do that.
这就带我们到了2号证人，吉姆·芬克尔。他在一家名为Dynamic Credit的公司工作，你们中有些人可能还记得他之前在《美国生活》某一集《巨大的金钱池》里的表现。他就是那个参与组装评级机构正在评级的结构化金融交易的人。他站在华尔街那一边。
This brings us to witness number 2, Jim Finkel. He works at a company called Dynamic Credit, and some of you might remember him from an earlier This American Life episode, The Giant Pool of Money. He was the guy putting together some of these structured finance deals that the rating agencies were rating. He was with Wall Street.
他说出了许多人的心声：评级机构之所以没有直接说“不”、给一切踩下刹车的一个原因是，那样做会让他们损失金钱。评级机构从创建和出售债券的华尔街投资银行那里获得报酬。如果一家评级机构对其中一家说：“我不打算给你们这个新奇的债券评级，我没有足够的信息”，华尔街有一个答案，一个非常有说服力的答案。
And he says what a lot of people say: one reason the rating agencies didn't just say no, put the brakes on everything, it would have cost them money. The rating agencies get paid by the Wall Street investment banks who are creating and selling the bonds. If a rating agency said to one of them, I'm not going to rate this newfangled bond of yours, I don't have enough information, Wall Street had an answer, a very persuasive one.
华尔街说：“嘿，如果你不评，对面那家会评，我们会把所有业务都给他。”他们让评级机构相互竞争，而评级机构基本上正面临：我们准备好放弃40%的收入，就因为我们说我们还没准备好评定这种新产品吗？这对他们来说是金融自杀。
Wall Street said, hey, if you don't, the guy across the street will, and we'll give him all the business. And they played the rating agencies off one another and the rating agencies were basically facing, are we ready to give up 40% of our revenues because we're saying we're not ready to rate this kind of new product? It would have been financial suicide for them.
这是否意味着他们彻底废除了规则？不。但这是否意味着他们可能会在这里或那里做出妥协？也许。
Does it mean they get rid of their rules altogether? No. But does it mean they might make compromises here or there? Maybe.
费利西亚·格鲁梅特，像吉姆·芬克尔一样，曾在华尔街的贝尔斯登工作。我们叫她2A证人。她也创造了这些债券，她解释了她是如何试图从评级机构获得她想要的评级的。
Felicia Grumet, like Jim Finkel, worked on Wall Street, at Bear Stearns. We'll call her witness 2A. She also created these bonds, and she explained how she would try and get the rating she wanted from the rating agencies.
例如，有时她有一种新的交易类型需要评级。评级机构对这类新事物没有固定的方法论，所以她的团队会提出一种结构，试图让尽可能多的交易获得AAA评级。
For instance, sometimes she'd have a new type of deal she needed to get rated. The rating agencies didn't have a set methodology for rating something new like this, and so her team would propose a structure to try to get as much of the deal Triple A as possible.
在某种程度上，我们参与了与他们一起开发方法论，因为我们会试图争论“你应该从这个或那个角度来看待它”。他们会回去他们的委员会或其他什么机构，然后回到我们这里说：“好吧，这是我们预期的AAA级债券和其他债券结构水平。”我们可能会说：“好吧，那行不通，你们必须回到绘图板上。”
In some ways, we were part of developing the methodology with them because we'd be trying to argue you should look at it this way or that way. And they would go off on their end and their committees or whatever, and they would come back to us and say, well, this is our expected levels of Triple A and other bonds in the structure. And we might say, well, that doesn't work, you have to go back to the drawing board, so to speak.
我们需要更多的AAA。
We need more Triple A.
这真的发生得那么具体吗？我不知道。但那是其中的一部分。那是其中的一部分。
Did it happen that specifically? I don't know. But that was part of it. That was part of it.
费利西亚和我聊了很久，所以她说，从每笔交易中榨取最多的价值，从规则中寻找每一个漏洞，那只是你做的事情。那是华尔街每个人的工作。
Felicia and I had talked for a long time, and so said that eking the most out of every deal, scouring the rules for every loophole, that was just what you did. That was everyone's job on Wall Street.
这让我感觉非常糟糕，所以实际上我很难承认这一点。
It makes me feel really bad, so actually it's very hard for me to acknowledge.
为什么这让你感觉糟糕？
Why does it make you feel bad?
因为我知道我在做什么。
Because I knew what I was doing.
是的。
Yeah.
我知道我在做绕过规则的事情。我不为此感到骄傲，但我还是做了。
I knew I was doing things to get around the rules. And I wasn't proud of it, but I did it anyway.
当许多此类证券被评为AAA级时，你有没有想过，“这绝不可能是什么AAA级”？
When a lot of these securities were being rated Triple A, did you think, there's no way that's Triple A?
绝对想过。
Absolutely.
再次请出结构化金融经理吉姆·芬克尔。
Again, Structured Finance Manager Jim Finkel.
我们看到的评级有些对我们来说毫无意义。我们了解评级机构的模型和指标，我们可以自己复制它们，但我们无法理解他们在做什么。
There were ratings that we saw that made no sense to us. We knew the rating agency models and metrics, and we could replicate them ourselves, and we couldn't make sense of what they were doing.
他们给你的东西评级比你认为的要高吗？
Did they rate your stuff higher than you thought it should have been rated?
我想我们对所有这些CDO产品获得的评级感到惊讶。很难说我们不喜欢我们能获得评级的事实。老实说，这本身可能阻止了我们问自己那个非常困难的问题：这个评级是否公正。
I think we marveled at the ratings that all these CDO products got. It was very hard to say that we didn't enjoy the fact that we could get a rating. And to be honest with you, that in and of itself probably prevented us from asking ourselves the very difficult question of was that rating just or not.
好的，戴夫，我们只有最后一位控方证人。她来自我们尚未听到的这件事的那个角落：投资者。
OK, Dave, we just have one final witness for the prosecution. She comes from the one corner of this whole thing that we haven't heard from: the investor.
梅贝尔·余，是的。她在先锋集团工作，管理着4000亿美元的债券投资。每当一项新的结构化金融交易出现时，这些带着AAA债券的交易就会落在她的办公桌上，以及像她这样成百上千人的桌上。这些交易对许多投资者来说看起来很棒，但对梅贝尔·余来说并不好。
Mabel Yu, yeah. She worked at Vanguard, which manages $400 billion in bond investments. And every time a new structured finance deal came out, these deals, with their Triple A bonds, would land on her desk and on the desks of hundreds of people like her. And those deals looked great to a lot of investors, but they did not look great to Mabel Yu.
我拿到了评级机构分析师的名字，并问了他们很多问题。起初，问题会持续15分钟到半小时，但后来对我来说变成了一小时又一小时，以便我理解交易的风险状况。
I got names of the rating agencies analysts, and I asked them lots of questions. In the beginning, the questions would be 15 minutes to half an hour, but then it turned into hours and many hours for me to understand the risk profile of the deal.
他们对你说了什么？
And what did they say to you?
我问他们：“好的，AAA应该是最小风险。AAA真正的意思是，即使事情同时变坏，我们的投资者仍会受到保护。”这意味着如果经济下滑，如果房价下跌，如果利率上升，如果所有这些事情同时发生，我们的投资会怎么样？但我无法得到一个明确的答案。
I asked them, OK, Triple A is supposed to be minimum risk. What Triple A really means is, even if things go bad simultaneously, at the same time, our investors would still be protected. That means if the economy goes down, if the housing prices go down, if the interest rates go up, if all of those things happen at the same time, what would happen to our investment? And I could not get a straight answer.
他们有没有说：“看，你担心太多了，我们有很多聪明人在做这个”？
Did they say, look, you worry too much, we have a lot of smart people working on this?
很多，很多，很多，很多次。我感觉自己很笨，很多次。是的。他们以多种方式问我：别担心。享受生活。与其熬夜准备那么多小时的问题，不如去享受生活。我担心得太多了。几乎每天。
Many, many, many, many times. I felt so dumb many, many times. Yep. And they asked me, in many ways, they asked me, don't worry about it. Have a life. Instead of staying up so late and preparing all those hours of questions for them, just go and enjoy my life. I worry too much. Almost every day.
几乎每天？
Almost every day?
是的，是的，是的。
Yes, yes, yes.
如果你回顾过去，什么是被错过的？
If you look back, what was the thing that was missed?
我不会说有什么被错过了。
I wouldn't say anything was missed.
最后，这是被告，或者至少是被告的一名员工，汤姆·沃拉克。
And here, at long last, is the defendant, or at least an employee of the defendant, Tom Warrack.
他实际上曾经为弗兰克·雷特工作，就是农场里的那个家伙。
He actually used to work for Frank Raiter, the guy on the farm.
就是带乌龟的那个。沃拉克在标准普尔待了15年多。他参与评定了数百只抵押贷款支持证券。我们问他关于弗兰克·雷特的担忧，即抵押贷款发放给了信用评分低且几乎没有文件的借款人。
With the turtle. Warrack has been at Standard and Poor's for over 15 years. He's helped rate hundreds of mortgage-backed securities. And we asked him about Frank Raiter's concerns, that mortgages were being given out to a new type of borrower with low credit scores and little documentation.
在国家历史上，追溯到大萧条时期，我们从未有过全国范围内的房价下跌和相关的违约水平。
Never before in the history of the country, dating back to The Great Depression, have we had the type of nationwide declines in home prices and the associated default levels.
我的意思是，有些人会说这些贷款发放给了甚至不需要证明自己有工作的人。我们没有关于这些贷款将如何表现的数据。你们怎么能给这些东西评级？
I mean, there are people who would say these were loans given out to people who didn't even have to prove they had jobs. We had no data on how these loans were going to perform. How could you rate these things?
重要的是要理解，我们认为贷款风险越高，交易中就需要纳入更多的损失准备金，我们才能将交易评为AAA级。
It's important to understand, the riskier we believed the loan was, the more loss reserves needed to be incorporated into the transaction for us to rate a transaction Triple A.
但有些人会说你没有数据来了解那些人违约的真实风险。你怎么能去评定一种你根本没有关于贷款将如何表现数据的东西？
But there are people who would say you had no data to know what the real risk of those people defaulting was. How could you go and rate something where you didn't have any data on how these loans were going to perform?
嗯，我们有很多数据。我们有多年关于借款人随时间表现的数据。
Well, we had lots of data. We had years' worth of data as to as to how borrowers perform over time.
对于这些贷款？对于那些不需要证明自己有工作的人？你有这么多数据？
For these loans? For people who didn't have to prove they had a job? You had lots of data for that?
通过我们的分析过程，我们能够围绕我们认为这些特定借款人的未来会是什么样子来发展假设。
Through our analytical process, we're able to develop assumptions around what we believe the future will be like for these particular borrowers.
让我们检查最后一句。“我们能够围绕我们认为这些特定借款人的未来会是什么样子来发展假设。”我认为这是许多人感到沮丧的一点。那不是人们想听到的词。
Let's examine that last sentence. We are able to develop assumptions around what the future will be like for these particular borrowers. I think that's one frustration many people have. Those are not the words people are looking for.
人们想听到的词是这些：“对不起，我们错了。”穆迪拒绝了我们的采访请求，但标准普尔总裁德文·夏尔马同意与我们交谈。这是他最接近承认公司搞砸了的话。
The words people are looking for are these, I'm sorry, we were wrong. Moody's declined our request for interviews, but the president of Standard & Poor's, Deven Sharma, did agree to speak with us. Here's the closest he came to admitting that his company screwed up.
我们的一些抵押贷款相关证券经历了比我们历史上经历过的更严重的降级，这令人失望。
Some of our mortgage-related securities experienced more severe downgrades than we have historically experienced, and that's been a disappointment.
说实话，作为一个听众，令人沮丧的是，我听过很多次“没有人能预见到这一点”。比任何人都更清楚的是，那是你们的工作，对吧？投资银行的工作是说“这将是伟大的”。你们的工作是说“你知道吗？事情可能会变坏”。
I think, honestly, as a listener out there, this is the thing that is frustrating is that I've heard this a lot, that nobody could have seen this coming, nobody could have seen this coming. More than anybody else, that is your job. Right? It's the investment bank's jobs to say, this is going to be great. It's your job to say, you know what? Here's how things could go bad.
我们的分析师确实是非常聪明的人，他们也观察到泡沫太多了，我们需要做点什么。他们从2006年开始改变了我们的方法论和标准。现在回头看，感觉他们没有做出我们现在所经历的那么严重的改变。但并不是他们没看到。他们只是没看到它的严重性。
Our analysts are really smart people, and they too observed that there was too much of a bubble and we needed to do something about it. And they made changes to our methodology and criteria starting in 2006. Now, hindsight, it's like they didn't make enough of a severe change as we have now experienced. But it's not that they missed it. They missed the severity of it.
你们中的一些人可能会察觉到一个男人细腻的言辞剖析，他在我们20分钟的采访之前，可能经历了数小时的法律咨询。信用评级机构当然正在被起诉，他们不想说任何可以在法庭上对他们不利的话。显然，“听着，我们确实搞砸了，我们非常抱歉”可以在法庭上对你不利。结果，我们问了一个问题，得到的是一个发言稿式的回应。
Some of you may detect the delicate verbal parsing of a man who, before our 20-minute interview, had probably undergone many hours of legal counseling. The credit rating agencies are of course being sued, and they don't want to say anything that can be used against them in court. And, apparently, listen, we really screwed up, we're very sorry, can be used against you in court. As a result, we'd ask a question, and we'd get a talking point in response.
所以，我们发现自己处于一种奇怪的境地。我们通过喝啤酒、喝咖啡、打电话，与那些不想录音的前任和现任评级机构员工进行了很多次交谈。我们阅读了文章，参加了小组讨论，我们认为我们可以比他们任何官方发言人更清楚地解释他们的观点。
And so, we find ourselves in a strange position. We've had so many conversations over beer, over coffee, over the phone, with former and current rating agency employees who didn't wish to go on tape. We've read articles, we've sat through panel discussions, and we think we can explain their point of view more clearly than any of their official spokespeople.
好吧，我们要试一试。所以，亚历克斯，你想当评级机构，我当那个咄咄逼人的记者？
Well, we're going to try. So, Alex, you want to be the rating agency, I'll be the pitbull reporter?
好吧，放马过来吧，伙计。
All right, bring it on, man.
好吧。从哪里开始？这个怎么样？看，当你把某样东西评为AAA时，它应该很安全，它应该非常安全，它应该如此安全以至于评级根本不应该改变，然而你在泡沫期间评为AAA的证券中，有近一半已经被降级了。解释一下。
All right. Where to start? How about this? Look, when you rate something Triple A, it's supposed to be safe, it's supposed to be really safe, it's supposed to be so safe that the rating really shouldn't change, and yet nearly half, 1/2 of the securities you rated Triple A during the bubble, they've been downgraded. Explain that.
好吧，那些字母等级，AAA和BBB，那只是我们最好的估计。它们不是买入或卖出建议。投资者只是没有正确使用我们的评级。他们本应该更像梅贝尔·余，问更多问题。他们本应该得出自己的结论。
OK, those letter grades, the Triple A's and Triple B's, those are just our best estimate. They're not a buy or sell recommendation. Investors just weren't using our ratings properly. They should have been more like Mabel Yu, asking more questions. They should have come up with their own conclusions.
而且，改变评级是明智的。经济已经跌落悬崖了。你想让我确保我的评级永远不下降？行，我会把一切都评为CCC。哦，顺便说一句，我们在互联网上发布了我们所有的模型。如果你想的话，你一直可以看到我们是怎么得出评级的。
And besides, it's smart to change the ratings. The economy has fallen off a cliff. You want me to make sure my ratings never go down? Fine, I'll rate everything Triple C. Oh, and by the way, we publish all our models on the internet. You can see how we came up with a rating all along if you wanted to.
是的，但关于你是被你正在评级的证券的人支付工资这一事实呢？
Yeah, but what about the fact that you were paid by the people whose securities you were rating?
先生，认为有人能从我们这里买到评级的想法？你冒犯了我。看，有人必须支付我们。要么是发行人，要么是买家。无论哪种方式都有利益冲突。我们知道这一点，我们会处理它。
Sir, the notion that someone could buy a rating from us? You offend me. Look, someone has to pay us. It's either the issuers or the buyers. There are conflicts of interest either way. We know that and we deal with it.
我们绝大多数评级都是站得住脚的。我们为价值数万亿美元的各种债券评级。其中大多数表现得完全正如我们所预期的那样。抵押贷款相关债券只是我们所做工作的一小部分。
The vast majority of our ratings held up. We rate trillions of dollars of all kinds of bonds. Most of them have behaved exactly as we expected them to. Mortgage-related bonds are a small part of what we do.
而且无论如何，把这一切都归咎于我们是完全不公平的。华尔街和抵押贷款发放者对我们撒了谎。投资者变得懒惰，在没有进行尽职调查的情况下就购买了这些东西。你想知道我想什么吗？我认为我们是一个方便的替罪羊，我们正被你和其他所有人用来避免审视他们自己的错误。
And anyway, it's totally unfair to put all of this on us. Wall Street and mortgage lenders lied to us. Investors got lazy and bought the stuff without doing their own due diligence. You want to know what I think? I think we are a convenient scapegoat, and we're being used by you and everybody else to avoid examining their own mistakes.
你完了吗？
Are you done?
是的，把它说出来感觉真好。我现在回来了。
Yeah, it actually felt good to get that off my chest. I'm back now.
好的，因为还有其他事情我们需要谈，那就是背景故事。
OK, because there's something else we need to talk about, which is the back story.
对，背景故事。这些公司是如何从1917年发布它们的小铁路指南，变成全球金融崩溃的核心的？
Right, the back story. How did these companies go from publishing their little railroad guides in 1917 to being at the center of a global financial meltdown?
为了找到答案，我们去和纽约大学一位名叫拉里·怀特的教授谈了谈。当我们说教授时，我们指的是全套装备：灰色、稍微有点不修边际的头发，一条以纳斯达克股票代码为特色的新奇领带。在他办公室的许多书架中，拉里·怀特确定这就是那位播下我们当前危机种子的男人的名字。
To find the answer, we went to talk to a professor at NYU named Larry White. And when we say professor, we mean the whole package: gray, slightly unkempt hair, a novelty tie featuring NASDAQ ticker symbols. And in one of the many books in his office, Larry White is sure is the name of the one man who planted the seeds of our current crisis.
啊，审计官，啊，达达……是吉恩·怀特的书吗？J.F.T·奥康纳，33年到38年的审计官。他是你要找的人，J.F.T·奥康纳。他是你要找的人。
Ah, the comptroller, ah, da-da, da-da, da-da, da-da. Comptroller of the Currency . Is this Gene White's book? J.F.T O'Connor, comptroller '33 to '38. He's your man, J.F.T O'Connor. He's your man.
我们要找的奥康纳，是富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福在大萧条最严重时期的货币审计官。在大萧条期间，奥康纳的工作是修复银行体系。他做了看起来完全合理且谨慎的事情，试图阻止银行承担太多风险。
Our man, J.F.T. O'Connor, was Franklin Delano Roosevelt's comptroller of the currency at the height of The Great Depression. During The Depression, it was O'Connor's job to fix the banking system. And he did what seemed like a totally reasonable and prudent thing, to try to keep the banks from taking too many risks.
1936年，货币审计官告诉银行，它们不能持有低于投资级别的债券。由谁确定投资级别？由少数评级机构。理由非常充分，目标无疑也很合理，但它所做的是将我们送上了将这少数评级机构的判断赋予法律效力的道路。
In 1936, the comptroller of the currency tells the banks that they cannot hold bonds that are below investment grade. Investment grade as determined by whom? By a handful of rating agencies. Perfectly good reasoning, certainly a sensible goal, but what it did was send us down this road of vesting the judgments of these handful of rating agencies with the force of law.
怀特教授说，这是一个关键时刻，因为现在评级机构的小字母等级有了非常特殊的含义。以前这个工具只是投资者使用的工具，现在评级变成了要求。
This, says Professor White, was a pivotal moment, because now the rating agencies' little letter grades took on a very special meaning. Whereas before the tool was just a tool for investors to use, now the rating became a requirement.
事情并没有就此结束。1975年，SEC，证券交易委员会，通过了一项规则，规定金融机构不能仅仅依赖任何评级机构的评级，而只能依赖专门指定的评级机构。多年来，这意味着只有三家：穆迪、标准普尔和惠誉。
And things didn't just end there. In 1975, the SEC, The Securities and Exchange Commission, passed a rule saying, financial institutions couldn't rely on the ratings of just any rating agency, but only on specially designated ones. For many years, that meant just three: Moody's, Standard & Poor's, and Fitch.
各州加入行列，开始要求养老基金投资和保险公司进行评级。甚至金融行业也参与进来，并将评级要求写入了它们自己的交易中。
States jumped on the bandwagon and started requiring ratings for pension fund investments and for insurance companies. Even the financial industry got involved and wrote ratings requirements into its own deals.
于是，这三家公司和它们的字母等级成了数万亿美元投资的基础。仿佛在没有完全意识到的情况下，世界已经用炸药为全球经济接线，而评级就是导火索。然后，在2007年7月10日，第一根导火索被点燃。穆迪看到了情况，将数百只次级抵押贷款债券降级。标准普尔说它也会。
And so, these three companies and their letter grades became the foundation for trillions of dollars of investments. It was as if, without fully realizing it, the world had wired the global economy with explosives, and the ratings were the fuse. And then, on July 10, 2007, the first fuses got lit. Moody's saw the light and downgraded hundreds of subprime bonds. Standard & Poor's said it would too.
在不久前发布的一份新闻稿中，穆迪表示它已经将399只住宅抵押贷款支持证券降级，并将另外32只置于可能降级的审查之下。这些最初都是——
In a press release issued not very long ago, Moody's says it has downgraded 399 residential mortgage-backed securities, placed an additional 32 under review for possible downgrade. These were all originally--
当它在电视上发生时，看起来并不是什么大不了的事。毕竟，那是07年的夏天。道琼斯指数接近历史高点。衰退尚未开始。穆迪的这一宣布在《纽约时报》的商业版面得到了提及，但头版头条是“你的房子卖不掉？也许是定价太低了。”
As it was happening on TV, it didn't seem like that big a deal. This, after all, was the summer of '07. The Dow was near its all-time high. The recession had not yet begun. This announcement by Moody's got a mention in the business section of the New York Times , but the front page featured the headline, "Can't Sell Your Home? Maybe it's Priced Too Low."
杰里·冯斯当时就在穆迪内部。
Jerry Fons was inside Moody's at the time.
真的，从内部看，并没有引起多大的反响。他们试图说，好吧，模型显示这些有点虚弱，所以我们现在看到这里有些恶化，所以我们要降低它们。事情处理得很平淡。但他们无法看到的是，情况确实在大规模恶化。
Really, internally, it was not much hay was made of it. They tried to say, well, the model shows these are a little weak, and so we see now there's some deterioration here, so we're going to lower them. It was done very matter of factly. But what they couldn't see is that the wheels were really coming off big time.
我确实记得我称之为“链锯屠杀”的事情。
I do kind of remember what I call the chainsaw massacre.
吉姆·芬克尔，正如你所听到的，对降级的看法有点不同。记住，芬克尔是华尔街结构化金融的人。过去几年他一直在创建、管理并将自己的钱投资于CDO，这些CDO由许多债券组成，其中许多债券现在正在被降级。
Jim Finkel, as you can hear, saw the downgrades a little differently. Finkel, remember, is the Wall Street structured finance guy. He'd spent the last few years creating and managing and investing his own money in CDOs, which were made up of lots of bonds, many of which were now being downgraded.
他能看出事情会蔓延。看着那些评级下调，吉姆说会议室一片寂静，电话没有响，每个人都在看同一件事。
He could see things were going to spread. And watching those ratings downgrades, Jim said the room was silent, the phones weren't ringing, everyone was watching the same thing.
我记得那是个炎热的夏日。我记得坐在办公室里，盯着屏幕，看着屏幕工作的方式，被降级的单个证券一行一行地出现。你忘了那里有多少证券，更不用说一天之内有多少会被降级。
I remember it being a hot summer day. I remember sitting in the office, watching the screens and watching the way the screens work, the individual securities being downgraded come over line by line. You forgot how many securities there were out there, let alone how many could get downgraded all in one day.
那简直是一波又一波坏消息，就像身体被重击。我只觉得空虚和无助。而吸收这些影响实际上相当困难。我们知道它有影响，但我们确实很难概念化那些评级影响的严重程度，以及这会如何演变成系统性问题。
And it was just wave after wave after wave of bad information, and it's like body blows. I just felt hollow and helpless. And it was actually quite hard to absorb the implications. We knew there was an implication to it, but we actually were having a hard time conceptualizing the magnitude of the implication of those ratings, and how systemic this would roll out to be.
所以脚下的世界在颤抖并不是我想用的比喻。更像是某种耳语般的死亡之风吹过房间。
So the world sharking under your feet wasn't really quite the metaphor I'd use. It was more some kind of whispering death wind blowing through the room.
在接下来的一年半里，那股死亡之风变得越来越大。最初的降级之后是更高等级债券的更多降级。记住，许多金融机构法律要求持有高于特定评级的债券。
Over the next year and a half, that death wind grew louder. Those first downgrades were followed by more downgrades of higher and higher rated bonds. And remember, a lot of financial institutions were required by law to hold bonds that were above a certain rating.
现在它们必须出售，因为它们都在同一时间出售，价格下跌。这些下跌的价格破坏了持有这些债券的银行的稳定性：花旗银行、美林证券、雷曼兄弟。最终它波及到了AIG。
Now they had to sell, and because they were all selling at the same time, prices dropped. These dropping prices destabilized the banks which held these bonds: Citibank, Merrill Lynch, Lehman Brothers. Eventually it made its way to AIG.
我们回来了，各位。当然，关于AIG有更多新闻。穆迪现在也下调了AIG的评级。想给你们提供那里的细节。这些降级将对AIG触发某些东西，将迫使——
We're back, everybody. We have more news, of course, on AIG. Moody's has now downgraded AIG as well. Want to give you the details there. Those downgrades will have the effect of triggering certain things for AIG that will force--
评级获得了一种它们真的不想要的力量。
Ratings have gained a power that they really didn't want to have.
杰里·冯斯，穆迪前经理。
Jerry Fons, the former manager at Moody's.
无论你是否真的是A级，如果穆迪说你是，你就是。一旦它们下调你，你就会破产。
Whether or not you really are a Single A, if Moody's says you are, you are. And as soon as they downgrade you, you're going to be bankrupt.
所以，基本上，评级机构，你们被赋予了所有这些权力，一开始你们甚至不知道你们——它后来才出现。你们开始评级，然后突然之间你的评级具有了市场影响力，如果你改变它，那不仅仅是改变一家公司的评级。整个体系基本上崩溃了。
And so, basically, the ratings agencies, you guys were given all this power that all of a sudden you didn't even, in the beginning, you didn't even know that you were-- it sort of came later. You started the ratings, and then all of a sudden your rating has this market force, that if you change it, it's much more than just changing the rating on a single company. The whole system collapses, basically.
没错。未来能做什么？我认为我们必须从根本上重新思考整个业务。我认为它坏了。我认为人们依赖评级的方式导致了他们的垮台。我们必须摆脱对两三家大公司的依赖，让它们为你做所有的工作。
That's right. What could be done in the future? I think we have to rethink the whole business from ground up. I think it's broken. I think the way people have relied on ratings has contributed to their downfall. We've just got to move away from this dependence on two or three big companies to do all your work for you.
评级机构本身当然没有导致我们所有的经济问题。对于这一点，有很多责任需要分担。但在上升的过程中，它们帮助吹大了房地产泡沫。而在下降的过程中，它们有时是持有销毁泡沫大头针的人。
The rating agencies on their own certainly didn't cause all our economic problems. There's plenty of blame to go around for that. But on the way up, they helped inflate the housing bubble. And on the way down, they were sometimes the ones holding the pin to pop it.
桌上有很多关于如何用杰里·冯斯的话“重新思考整个业务”的建议。一个想法是，债券应该从投资者支付的评级机构那里得到一种怀疑的“第二意见”。另一个将建立一个系统来奖励评级正确的机构。另一个想法，完全将评级从法规中剔除。
There are all kinds of proposals on the table for how, in Jerry Fons' word, to rethink the whole business. One idea is that bonds should get a kind of skeptical second opinion from a rating agency paid by investors. Another would set up a system to reward agencies that get their ratings right. Another idea, get ratings out of regulations completely.
顺便说一句，两家最大的评级机构，穆迪和标准普尔，对此会没意见，愿意放弃它们的特殊法律地位。世界可能视它们为守望者，那些本可以阻止这场全球危机的人，但它们不这样看自己，或者至少它们不想再那样看了。获得所有业务很好。承担所有指责可没那么好。
The two biggest rating agencies, by the way, Moody's and Standard & Poor's, would be fine with that, would be willing to give up their special legal status. The world may see them as watchmen, the people who could have stopped this global crisis, but they don't see themselves that way, or at least they don't want to anymore. It's nice to get all the business. It's not so nice to get all the blame.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们节目的制片人之一。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是NPR新闻的记者。如果你喜欢今天听到的内容，大卫和亚历克斯和查娜实际上确实有一个博客，还有一个每周三次的播客，是我们节目和NPR新闻的共同制作，名为“钱的星球”（Planet Money）。www.npr.org/money。
Alex Blumberg is one of the producers of our show. David Kestenbaum is a correspondent for NPR News. And if you like what you heard today, David and Alex and Chana actually, in fact, do a blog and a thrice-weekly podcast that is a co-production between our program and NPR News called Planet Money. www.npr.org/money.
[鸣谢]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
[资金鸣谢]
[FUNDING CREDITS]
还有WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督，我们的老板，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他刚从希腊度假回来。他在到处走动时遇到了困难。他说标志真的很奇怪。
And WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who just got back from his vacation in Greece. He had trouble getting around. He says the signage was really weird.
看起来有很多希腊字母。
It looked like a lot of Greek letters.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。